The Athenian hero of the Greco-Persian war,
the man who devised the tactic that tricked
the Persian navy into an ambush, the man who
set Athens on a course of naval dominance,
Themistocles, was ostracized in c. 471 BCE
from the very city he served so dearly for
so long.
The reasons behind Themistocles’ ostracism
are far from simple.
Sure, he was becoming too arrogant, and sure,
he was accused of taking bribes, but his ostracism
was also part of a greater political battle
happening in Athens at the time.
In the 470s and 460s, the two most prominent
political debates or movements in Athens could
be described as the democratic movement and
the conservative movement.
Both factions supported the Delian league
and the continuation of the war with Persia,
but they disagreed about how to handle Sparta
and how to run the Athenian democracy.
The conservatives hoped to not necessarily
ally with Sparta but at least not anger them
or antagonize them.
In other words, they wanted to keep the Spartan-Athenian
relations as amicable as possible.
They also generally wanted a more limited
democracy with most of the political power
resting in the hands of the quote ‘better
classes’ or, in other words, the upper classes.
The democrats, on the other hand, wanted to
hinder the Spartan expansion of power, and
in general, they wanted to cause as much nuisance
to the Spartans as possible.
The democrats were also in favour of a more
radical democracy.
In other words, they wanted to divide the
political power equally among all the Athenian
citizens regardless of their class.
With that said, Athens didn’t really have
political parties in the way we would understand
them.
As Tridimas states ‘in the direct democracy
of Athens, Assembly voters voted on each item
debated, rather than platforms bundling several
issues … when it is possible to vote on
any single issue, the number of divisions
among citizens is extremely large; every single
issue may generate a different coalition of
interests.
This implies that Assembly voting on each
policy item made impossible the emergence
of stable, organized groups.’
The people voting for what I called the conservative
movement, or the democratic movement would
not have seen themselves as part of some democratic
or conservative faction.
They were all just people voting according
to their own beliefs, which were often shaped
by the most prominent politicians of the time
but which, due to how the Athenian government
was structured, did not lead to any organization
of active political parties.
A source from the late 5th century even mentions
that forming political societies in Athens
was illegal.
With that said, despite there not being any
political parties, we can, with hindsight,
observe political trends and movements happening
in Athens, which often revolved around the
most prominent politicians of the time.
So, when I talk about the conservatives or
the democrats, I am talking about these greater
political movements, not actual political
parties.
Anyways, for much of the 470s, Athenian politics
seemed to have been dominated by the democratic
movement, which can be seen through the political
prominence of its largest supporter of the
time, Themistocles.
Themistocles did all he could to hinder any
kind of Spartan plans in Greece.
He tricked them when they protested the rebuilding
of the Athenian walls (see my first video
in the series).
Through diplomatic cunning, he stopped their
efforts to gain political control over Delphi,
and he specifically pushed for the Athenian
naval build-up to contrast Sparta and its
land army.
According to Plutarch, he was also the champion
of the common people, fighting for their democratic
rights against the conservative movement.
However, by the end of the 470s, a new and
very prominent political player emerged in
Athens, Cimon, who initially had the backing
of the late champion of the upper classes,
Aristides.
Coming from an old aristocratic family, Cimon
was a staunch conservative who wanted political
power to be largely held by the upper classes.
He also loved the Spartans.
He had many friends and allies in Sparta and
was even appointed by the Spartans as their
proxenos, meaning he was chosen by the Spartans
to be their official Athenian diplomat.
Cimon’s initial exploits and victories as
the Delian League’s military leader gave
him much fame in Athens.
After all, he conquered Thrace and Skyros,
found the bones of Theseus, brought a lot
of money to Athens through the slaves and
booty he acquired during his conquests, and
even funded many new building projects.
He funded the expansion of the city’s defences
and the rebuilding of the shrine of Theseus,
the Athenian Academy, and the Acropolis.
He also funded an overall refurbishment of
the city, fixing old roads, adding new trees
and gardens and draining the swamps between
Athens and Piraeus.
All these military exploits and building projects
made Cimon very popular in Athens, which in
turn made the conservative movement, which
he championed, also popular.
Hence, Themistocles’ ostracism in c. 471
can be seen as a pivotal moment in Athenian
politics when the conservative movement, thanks
largely to Cimon, started to dominate over
the democratic movement.
The Spartans used the fact that the conservative
pro-Spartan movement was at its height in
Athens to their advantage.
Ever since Themistocles tricked them during
the whole Athenian wall-building project,
they hated him with a passion and wanted to
see him destroyed.
So, when he was ostracized, Sparta seized
the opportunity and came forth with evidence
that implicated Themistocles in Pausanias’
plot.
Pausanias was the Spartan general accused
of working with the Persian king to overthrow
Greece . Athens took the Spartan accusations
seriously and either tried and declared Themistocles
guilty in absentia or sent soldiers to retrieve
Themistocles from exile in order to be tried
in Athens.
The sources are unclear.
All we know is that Athens did send soldiers,
along with some Spartan volunteers, to take
Themistocles into custody.
Themistocles, knowing he was either already
declared guilty of conspiring with the Persian
King or that he would be declared guilty in
the now conservative-leaning Athens, tried
fleeing to various places around Greece, but
every time he would arrive somewhere, he would
be soon forced to leave due to the relentlessness
of the soldiers hunting him.
With no other choice, Themistocles decided
to flee Greece entirely to the very kingdom
he was accused of conspiring with, Persia.
Whether Themistocles was actually guilty,
as well as Pausanias, is honestly impossible
to know.
After all, it all happened 2500 years ago.
When Themistocles arrived in Persia, he met
with the king and was said to have impressed
the king so much that he was given a small
governorship in Asia Minor, bordering the
Ionian cities of the Delian League.
Also, while all of this was happening, Themistocles’
wife and kids, along with some of his possessions,
were smuggled to him out of Athens by some
of his friends.
Themistocles would eventually die in Asia
minor while serving the Persian king as his
governor, and so ended the life of one of
the most well-known military tricksters of
the Greco-Persian War.
Meanwhile, in the Delian League, after the
brief respite in the war with Persia due to
the Naxian rebellion, Cimon, in c. 467, planned
a Delian League expedition to quote ‘liberate’
more Greek cities and conquer Persian ones
located in Lycia and Pamphylia.
In preparation for this expedition, Cimon
widened the Athenian triremes in order for
them to be able to hold more hoplites on their
decks, so when they would board enemy ships,
they would always have a numbers advantage.
With about 200 of these widened triremes,
Cimon set sail for Asia Minor.
As the Delian League forces were conquering
the coastline of today’s southwestern Turkey,
Cimon found out that much of the Persian navy
, about 350 triremes strong, was anchored
at the mouth of a nearby river called Eurymedon,
hiding from the Athenians and waiting for
naval reinforcements to come from Cyprus.
Cimon, hoping to defeat the Persian navy before
it could be reinforced, quickly attacked the
anchored navy.
The Persians didn’t want to fight, hoping
to wait for the reinforcements, but Cimons
quick attack forced their hand, and so a battle
ensued in which the widen triremes of Cimon
proved extremely successful, and the Persian
navy was forced to retreat, running their
ships aground and fleeing to meet up with
the Persian army stationed nearby.
Cimon, eager to push his advantage, also disembarked
his troops and proceeded to engage with the
Persians.
According to Diodorus, the Persian army did
not expect to encounter a sizable enemy, for
they thought the Greeks only had a naval force
in the area and were unaware of the sizeable
number of hoplites on the widened triremes.
Therefore, when Cimon attacked with all his
disembarked hoplites, the Persians were caught
off guard by their sheer numbers and promptly
lost the battle.
Many of the Persian sailors and soldiers were
enslaved, their camp was looted, and their
ships destroyed.
According to Plutarch, this victory was still
not enough for Cimon, who forced a portion
of his navy back out to sea to confront the
incoming Persian naval reinforcements.
Caught off guard and unaware of what happened
to the main Persian navy, the remaining Persian
navy, in a confused panic, was easily defeated.
With this one land and sea battle, Cimon managed
to destroy most of the Persian navy, and Persia
ceased to be a serious naval threat to Greece
for the next 17 years.
Cimon returned to Athens, even more of a hero
than he already was, bringing with him more
slaves, more booty, and yet more expansion
of the Delian League.
Whether the new cities in Lycia and Pamphylia
wanted to actually join the league or were
forcefully coerced by Athens to join is hard
to say and has been a matter of debate by
historians.
Nevertheless, this did not matter to the Athenians,
who certainly must have seen the expansion
of a league of which they were a hegemon as
a positive.
Cimon’s ever-growing popularity expanded
the power of the conservative movement in
Athens even more, which started to threaten
the Athenian democratic system.
This is because a lot of the conservatives
tended to favour a limited democracy.
The people who voted for the conservative
agenda wanted most of the political power
to be held by the upper classes or, as Aristotle
called them, the ‘better classes’ rather
than sharing political power with the inexperienced
rabble.
This is not to say that all the conservative
voting people were only from the upper classes.
There certainly were poorer people that argued
for the conservative cause.
After all, most Athenians were not part of
the upper class, so the fact that the conservative
movement was so prominent must also imply
some sort of support from the lower classes
.
Now, in order to understand what Cimon and
the conservatives were doing to undermine
the Athenian democracy, we must first understand
the current political system of Athens, which
began in the late 6th century, and to help
me explain that system here’s a small but
very knowledgeable historytuber, Nothing New.
---------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------
Thanks Matus (pronounced Matoos), the Athenian
system of government in c. 465 was built on
the reforms of Cleisthenes, which were enacted
around 508-507.
Before these reforms, Athens was divided into
three main factions, the shore, the hill,
and the plain, which were headed by various
aristocrats.
This meant that a politician like Pisistratus
could use his popularity to seize power and
establish a single-rule tyranny, which often
seemed like a preferable option compared to
a city dominated by fierce rivalries between
factions.
These were the issues which Cleisthenes would
have to solve in order to secure the democracy
that Athens would become famous for: he needed
to break up the traditional tribes and the
strong influence of the old noble families,
and he needed to find a way to stop particular
politicians from gaining too much power through
popularity.
Cleisthenes achieved this by reforming the
political system of Athens, which had existed
since the earlier reforms of Solon.
First, Cleisthenes abolished the four traditional
Ionian tribes that divided Athens and reorganized
the city into ten new tribes.
He did this by dividing the three main geographical
areas into multiple smaller subdivision s
and then took the new subdivisions from each
geographical area and combined them to form
10 completely new tribes.
This effectively broke up the old Athenian
factions and the power of the noble families.
Conscription, elections, jury appointments,
and more were all done through these new 10
tribes of Athens.
Second, Cleisthenes gave more power to the
Athenian Assembly.
The Assembly allowed every Athenian citizen
to speak their mind and vote on all matters
concerning the city-state, its laws, and elected
government officials.
While the Assembly included all citizens,
we should keep in mind that this excluded
women, children, (knowns as metics) foreign
residents, and slaves, who were denied the
rights of citizenship.
Under Cleisthenes, the Assembly essentially
became the most important branch of government
in Athens.
Third, Cleisthenes also gave more power to
the council of 500, known as the Boule, which
guided and prepared the agenda for the Assembly
and functioned as the executive branch of
the government.
The reorganization of the tribes required
Cleisthenes to expand the Boule from four
hundred to five hundred members, with fifty
members chosen annually by random selection
from a group of volunteers coming from each
of the ten tribes.
Fourth, Cleisthenes took away much of the
power of the nine archons, which were the
chief magistrates of the city.
Before Cleisthenes’ reforms, the Archons
were the main executive branch of the government,
but since Cleisthenes gave much of this power
to the Boule, the archons became symbolic
figureheads overseeing religious, military,
and political celebrations (and events).
By c. 465, the archons, just like the members
of the Boule, were elected by lot from a group
of 500 volunteers, again 50 from each tribe.
Fifth, Cleisthenes reorganized the military,
with each tribe electing an infantry commander,
a cavalry commander, and most importantly,
a general.
The board of the ten generals , known as strategoi,
oversaw all matters relating to the Athenian
military and later also the Delian League
military.
By c. 465, the strategoi were the only high-ranking
government office in Athens that was elected
by popular vote and could also serve unlimited
consecutive terms .
Sixth, even though the Assembly served as
the final appeals court for most criminal
cases, Cleisthenes established a court system
for minor cases where jurors were selected
by lot from an annual roll of 6000 volunteers.
The Areopagus was the only branch of the Athenian
government that seems to have been untouched
by Cleisthenes’ reforms.
The Areopagus was a council of elders composed
of former archons, and its main function was
to scrutinize elected and government officials
and to judge serious crimes such as murders
.
Lastly, we should touch upon the use of sortition
in Athens, which was the process of choosing
government officials by random selection from
a group of volunteers, also known as election
by lot.
We don’t know when the first instance of
sortition occurred in Athens, but it most
likely emerged at some point in the 6th century,
with the largest expansion of its use taking
place during Cleisthenes’ reforms.
Initially, historians thought that the use
of sortition had a religious aspect in the
sense that the random result of the lot revealed
the will of the gods.
However, in recent years a closer examination
of the primary sources showed no connection
between election by lot and religion, meaning
that Athenians chose sortition due to perceived
practical benefits rather than religious reasons.
The actual practicality of election by lot
is a debate for another time but, as Hansen
states, ‘in the selection of magistrates
the Athenians preferred the lot to election
because it safeguarded the powers of the people
and obviated factionalism and corruption’,
which was yet another reason why Athens didn’t
have political parties.
This is the general picture of the Athenian
government in the fifth century that scholars
have been able to piece together, but we should
keep in mind how much we don’t know about
the exact functions of the different bodies
of government.
This overview was pretty brief in describing
the functions of the various branches of the
Athenian government simply because we just
don’t know that much about them.
Our understanding of Classical Athenian democracy
is incomplete because it relies entirely on
fragmentary inscriptions and testimonies of
later writers such as Aristotle and Herodotus.
It is also due to the nature of these sources
that while certain reforms are attributed
to legendary figures like Cleisthenes and
Solon, it is actually hard to say whether
Cleisthenes was responsible for instituting
everything attributed to him.
None the less, if you want to learn more about
Cleisthenes and other famous Athenian lawmakers,
head over to my channel and check out the
videos I made all about their lives and reforms.
---------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------------
Thank you Nothing New.
Definitely go check him out!
As you can see, the exact functions of all
the Athenian branches of government in c.
465 are not entirely known to us.
However, according to Aristotle and Plutarch,
during this time, Cimon and his conservative
allies were using the power of specifically
the Areopagus to control Athenian politics.
The way they did this was simple.
The Areopagus was composed of only former
archons.
In other words, people that already held a
political position.
As previously mentioned, archons were elected
by lot from a group of volunteers, so in theory,
any Athenian citizen could have become an
archon, but there were several caches.
First, none of the positions of the Athenian
government were paid.
Meaning only people who could financially
support themselves while doing their political
duties could realistically volunteer to be
elected by lot into government positions,
which meant that much of the government ended
up being filled by the upper classes, including
the Areopagus.
Second, one of Areopagus’ powers was to
quote ‘scrutinize’ incoming government
officials to ensure they were fit for the
job.
For example, making sure they don’t have
any criminal records or that they don’t
have any conflict of interest with their appointed
office, stuff like that.
Areopagus also had the power to prosecute
government officials once they were in office
or even after their term ended.
This power of scrutiny over the government
officials when they were elected, when they
were in office, and even when their office
ended meant that the Areopagus, even though
it couldn’t control the elections, could
control who would eventually become a government
official and through threats of prosecution
could even control their decisions while in
office.
Essentially, the Areopagus, which had an upper-class
majority, could control the membership of
all the elected branches of government making
sure the ‘better classes’ stayed in control.
This political power of the Areopagus became
increasingly utilized by Cimon and his conservative
allies in the late 470s and early 460s.
According to Aristotle, during this time,
the Aeropagus had the ‘superintendence of
affairs’ of Athens.
With that said, no matter how much political
control Cimon and the conservatives had through
the Areopagus, they still could not control
the most important branch of the Athenian
government, the Assembly.
The Assembly was where every Athenian citizen
could voice their opinion regardless of rank
or status, and it was here that the democratic
movement, which has been in decline since
the ostracism of Themistocles, found two new
quote ‘leaders of the people’.
Ephialtes and Pericles.
Both men came onto the political stage in
the 460s as Athenian strategoi, and they increasingly
started to be vocal in the Assembly against
Cimon, the conservatives, and the overreach
of power by the Areopagus.
Ephialtes was initially the more successful
democratic politician out of the two because,
unlike Pericles, who had an upper-class background,
Ephialtes, according to Aelian, came from
‘extreme poverty’ and so could connect
with the common people better than Pericles
could.
Since Cimon was the head of the Delian League
military, he was often away from Athens on
military expeditions, and it was these intermittent
absences of Cimon that Pericles and Ephialtes
exploited.
For example, when Cimon, after the battle
of Eurymedon, went to quote ‘liberate’
the cities of the Sea of Marmara , Pericles
and Ephialtes used Cimon’s absence to attack
him and the conservatives with everything
they could think of; from basic slander like
stating that Cimon was sleeping with his sister,
to more serious crimes like charges of bribery,
or accusations of undermining the Athenian
democracy.
However, despite these efforts by the new
leaders of the democratic movement, conservatives
still retained control of the Athenian government
mostly due to the still tremendous popularity
of Cimon.
But popularity in the public’s eye doesn’t
last forever.
Especially when Ares and Poseidon were eager
to test just how popular Cimon was, for a
new war and a natural disaster were just around
the corner.
Outro:
These Athenian videos never do that well,
but I really enjoy the history of classical
Athens and that’s why I keep making them.
Plus, there seems to be a small community
of my subscribers that does like these videos,
so these ones are for you guys!
Also, please go check out Nothing New, link
in the description, he has a great little
channel.
Other than that, thank you so much to my Patreons
and special thanks to my deity tear Patreons
Rohan, Crafty Criminalist, Bryan Lafata.
As always, my name is M. Laser and stick around
for history.